الفرقطه الروسيه الادميرال جوشكوف اول
سفينه بنيت على اساس ما يعرف بمشروع رقم
22 350 وصممت لاداء ادوار متعدده قادره
على تنفيذ ضربات طويله المدى لتدمير السفن
الحربيه والغواصات والقافله البحريه
ومجموعه الانزال البحري سميت السفينه
الاولى نسبه الى سيرجيو شيف ادميرال اسطول
الاتحاد السوفيتي تم البدء ببنائها في
فبراير 2006 وتم تشغيله نسخه الاولى منها
في يوليو 2018
235 مترا وعرضها 16 مترا وتضم طاقما يصل
الى نحو 120 اشخاص تميز الفرقاطه كرسنتها
من الاسلحه المدمر
16 خليه اطلاق عمودي مجهزه لحمله 16 صاروخ
مضاده للسفن يبلغ نحو 300 كيلو متر وتحمل
خلايا الاطلاق الصواريخ بعيده المدى من
نوع
بمدن يراوح بين 100 و2500 كلم كما انها
مزوده باثنتين وثلاثين خليه اطلاق عمودي
مجاهزه لحمل 32 صاروخ سطح جو للدفاع الجوي
وتتنوع بين النسخه البحريه لمنظومه اس 300
واس 400 اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجيو
شونجو اطلاقا صواريخ سيركون فوق الصوتيه
خلال مناوره اثناء مهمه فرقاطه الاميره في
المحيطين الاطلسي والهندي والبحر المتوسط
وصواريخ تزيد سرعتها على 10,000 كلم في
الساعه ويصير مداها الى الف كيلو متر
ويمكن اطلاقها من الجو والبر والبحر من
السفن والغواصات كما يمكن تزويدها برؤوس
حربيه مختلفه بما فيها النوويه حددت
البحريه الروسيه احتياجها الى عدد يرابح
بين 20 و30 فرقاطه من الادميره البورش وفي
2020 تمت الاشاره الى انه سيتم تخصيص
ثلاثه شوفونيل الاسطول الشمالي وثلاثه
لاسطول المحيط الهادئ واثنتين لاسطول
البحر الاسود